IT'S A GREAT NIGHT TO SIT BACK
R,
AND 1 AWAY FROM BY
LOWRY.
>> JETS STANDI STANLEY.
AND
HE'LL CHIP IT INANO.
INTO THE WINNIPEG ZONE GOES LIFE
SLOT RIGHT BETWEEN THE CIRCLCL .
WHO CAN'T FIND BACK TO THE STOPE
BY CONNOR IT IN
THE WINNIPEG ZON
BACKHANDED OFF THE GLASS.
BACK
HANGS IN THERE, COACHES CALL
THIS HOUNDING THE
OFF-SEASON.
SPIN MOVE BY LINDHOLM AT THE TOP
OF THE ZONETHE GOAL-SCORER FOR .
DEMELO MAKES IT HARD OFF THE
LANDS FLAT, TIME AND AGAIN, AND
HEIT BACK, THIS ONE SLOT.
LUNDESTROM BACK TO MANSON GETS
IT THROUGH, TRAFFIC GETZLAF,
>>Brian: LET'S TAKE LOOK THE JES
IN AND HE'S CAUGHT FTHER WAY
CAN'T CONNECT WITH RAKELL ON THL
WITH WINNIPEG HE ON LEFT WING SG
OFF THE SHOULDER OF HELLEBUYCK
AN
PUCK.
OPEN
SPACE, ANDD YOU'VE GOTTA BELIEVT
TREVOR ZEGRAS KNEW EXACTLY WHERE
HE WANUCKS, AN EMPTY
>>Brian: JOHN GIBSON IS GOING G.
>>John: COPP, WHO WON THE DRAW
ON THE EHLERS GOAL, WINS THE A F